ASSEMBLY MEMBER COLORADO
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
BARRICADING IN BENNETT BERMAN.
BIGELOW BLOOM. BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA. BURKE CALDERON CARILLO
CERVANTES CHAO JUNE. CHIU CHOI.
COOLEY COOPER. CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DALY. DAVIES LARA. FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN. GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON. GONZALEZ GRAY. GRAYSON
HOLDEN. IRWIN JONES SAWYER
KALRA KAMLAGER KILEY. LACKEY
LEE. LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY. MEDINA
MULLIN MURATSUCHI THE SYRIAN
WHEN O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH.
STONE D. VALIDATORS WE APPROVED
LAW VOEPEL WALDRON WARNER WEBER
WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO
ISRAEL. LET US PRAY. WE GIVE
THANKS FOR THE BREATHALYSED
THESE WORDS TO BE SHARED AS WE
ENTERED A NEW ERA IN AMERICAN
LIFE. ONLY WEEKS AFTER HAVING
WELCOMED A NEW YEAR. WE GIVE
THANKS FOR THE REST OF THOSE
WHO ARE HERE WITH US EVEN IF
THE PRESS IS A STRUGGLE. AND
THANKS TO THOSE WHO ARE HELD IN
INTENTION AND REFLECTION. ON
THIS DAY. WE DO NOT FORGET THAT
ALL PRESENT HERE ACROSS OUR
GOLDEN STATE. THROUGHOUT OUR
COUNTRY. AND IN EVERY CORNER OF
OUR WORLD HAVE KNOWN LOSS AT
THE HANDS OF THIS PANDEMIC.
HEARTACHE WILL BEARING WITNESS
TO INHUMANITY AND INJUSTICE. IN
FEAR. IN THE FACE OF FIRES AND
DISASTERS WHOSE INTENSITY IS
MAGNIFIED BY CLIMATE CHANGE.
YET AS THE GOOD REVEREND DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR SAID
IN THE SPRING OF NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT. THESE DAYS OF CHALLENGE
WILL MAKE AMERICA WHAT IT OUGHT
TO BE. WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO MAKE A BETTER NATION. AND I
WANT TO THANK GOD FOR ALLOWING
ME TO BE HERE WITH YOU WE'VE
GOT SOME DIFFICULT DAYS AHEAD.
BUT I'VE BEEN TO THE
MOUNTAINTOP AND I LOOKED OVER.
AND I'VE SEEN THE PROMISED
LAND. I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT
WE AS A PEOPLE. WILL GET TO THE
PROMISED LAND. THOSE WORDS BEAR
WITNESS TO OUR PRESENT DAY.
SADNESS MAY HAVE VISITED EVERY
DOORSTEP SUFFERING MAY HAVE
BEEN LAID AT THE FEET OF THOSE
CONSOLES ARE ALREADY WORN FOR.
ONE PAIR. BUT THE HOPE WE
INHERIT AND BEQUEATH ISN'T THAT
A COUPLE. AND THE LOVE THE
BIASES ON THIS LIVING OUR TO
OUR HUMANITY. IT'S MORE
RESOLUTE THAN EVER BEFORE. WE
CANNOT AND SHOULD NOT WAIT FOR
A MORE CONVENIENT SEASON TO
CHANGE THE COURSE OF ONE OF OUR
NATION. SO AS IT IS WRITTEN LET
US HOLD UNSWERVINGLY TO THE
HOPE WE PROFESS AND LET US
CONSIDER HOW WE MAY SPUR ONE
ANOTHER TOWARD LOVE. AND GOOD
DEEDS LET US NOT GIVE UP LET US
ENCOURAGE ONE ANOTHER
UNDERSTAND ALWAYS. ALMOND.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE. PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
BORN READY BEGIN I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE. TO THE FLAG. EIGHT
ZERO. AND. THANK YOU MAY BE
SEATED. READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL GOLDEN ONE CENTER
SACRAMENTO MONDAY DECEMBER
SEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY PURSUANT
TO THE PROVISIONS OF THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE OUR TWELVE
O'CLOCK THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO REGULAR SESSION OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE'S CALLED
ORDER BY C. PARKER. CHIEF CLERK
OF THE ASSEMBLY FOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY REGULAR SESSION
THE CONFORMING WITH THE LAW THE
FOLLOWING OFFICES WERE ALSO
PRESENT AB LEADS MANY CLOSE
RADIUS MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATION
AMPUTATIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR AND THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL. MS REYES YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE ONE EIGHT
EIGHT TO ALLOW. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE TO HAVE HER DAUGHTER
SEATED AT HER DESK TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CALDERON
CHOI DAVIES HOLDEN MEDINA
NGUYEN RAMOS MYSELF AND SMITH
TO SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY. AGAIN WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I MOVED TO ORDER H. R.
TAN CALDERON THROUGH THE THIRD
READING FILE. THE CLERK WILL
NOTE. WE KEEP OUR.
MEMBERS IN
THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO. PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. AND MEMBERS IF I COULD
HAVE YOUR ATTENTION PLEASE.
MEMBERS LAST NIGHT SACRAMENTO
DEPUTY SHERIFF ADAM GIBSON AND
K. NINE PARTNER RILEY.
TRAGICALLY LOST THEIR LIVES IN
THE LINE OF DUTY. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS COOPER AND
FLORA. WE ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
RISE SO WE MAY OBSERVE A MOMENT
OF SILENCE. TO HONOR THEIR
MEMORIES.
THANK YOU MEMBERS. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO TODAY'S
REMAINING ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PERMISSION TO SPEAK. ON
AN ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS AGAIN YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR CHECK YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR
OF THE ASSEMBLY.
MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
WE ARE ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MS REYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF A
FORMER MEMBER OF THIS BODY AND
A CHAMPION OF THE INLAND EMPIRE
JERRY EAVES. JERRY EAVES
POLITICAL LEGACY IN SAMBAR TO
DINO COUNTY SPANS NEARLY THIRTY
YEARS HE BEGAN HIS CAREER IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN. WHEN HE
WAS ELECTED TO THE RIALTO CITY
COUNCIL I WAS ELECTED MAYOR IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY. AFTER WORKING
FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS A KAISER
STEEL FOR YOU STARTED AS A
LABOR IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR
JERRY WAS ELECTED TO THE
ASSEMBLY TO REPRESENT THE SIXTY
SIX. ASSEMBLY DISTRICT WHICH
INCLUDED THE MANY OF THE CITIES
THAT NOW MAKE UP THE FORTY
SEVENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
WHICH I REPRESENT. HE WAS SOFT
SPOKEN BUT STRONG AND HIS
OPINIONS AND CONVICTIONS. IN
THIS TIME OF THE ASSEMBLY HE
WORKED ON MANY EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
THE PEOPLE OF SMBAR TO DINO
COUNTY INCLUDING DEVELOPMENT OF
THE ARROWHEAD REGIONAL MEDICAL
CENTER. HE ALSO WENT ON TO
SERVE ON THE SAMBAR TO DINO
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
THE EVENTUALLY BECAME CHAIR OF
THE BOARD. JERRY WAS WELL
RESPECTED FOR ALL OF HIS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS ESPECIALLY FOR
THOSE THAT BENEFITED THE INLAND
EMPIRE. HE WAS KNOWN FOR HIS
ABILITY TO WORK WELL WITH HIS
COLLEAGUES FROM ACROSS THE
AISLE. IN ADDITION TO HIS WIFE
JENNA EVEN THE SURVIVED BY HIS
DAUGHTER LAURA SCRANTON. A
BROTHER DARRELL. A SISTER BETTY
MULLIGAN THIRTEEN GRANDCHILDREN
EIGHT GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. AND
THREE GREAT GREAT GRANDCHILDREN
MEMBERS I REQUEST THAT WE TURN
IN THE MEMORY OF JERRY EAVES MY
FRIEND A FRIEND OF THIS
INSTITUTION AND A FRIEND OF THE
INLAND EMPIRE. THANK YOU MS
REYES MISTER RAMOS WHO ARE ALSO
RECOGNIZE AND SHERMAN MEMORY.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE WITH THE MAJORITY LEADER
AND RECOGNIZING- JERRY EAVES
JERRY IS ALSO- SERVED ON THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
WHICH WE ALL ALSO SERVED ON AS
A CHAIR FOR THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. UPON RUNNING FOR
THAT SEAT TO OF- THE PEOPLE
THAT THAT HELPED ME IN THAT
AREA WERE TO- LATINO GENTLEMAN
THAT SERVED- WITH JERRY EAVES
ONE WAS A MARTINE VALDEZ WHO
SERVED AS THE CHIEF OF STAFF.
AND A JOE RODRIGUEZ WHO ALSO
SERVED THERE AND THAT SHOWS THE
CHARACTER OF THE MAN THE MAN
THAT WAS WILLING TO GET ENGAGE
WITH THE COMMUNITY THAT WE
SERVE IN THE FIFTH DISTRICT OF
SAN BENITO COUNTY. AND BE ABLE
TO BE ABLE TO BRING THAT
DIVERSITY TO THE OFFICE FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN THE FIFTH
DISTRICT WE SEEN THAT HAPPEN.
SO WITH- JERRY EAVES BEING ABLE
TO BE THAT THAT CHAMPION THAT
THAT PAVING THE WAY FOR OUR
AREA THERE ALSO WAS BASE
CLOSURES THAT HAPPENED IN
DECEMBER DINO COUNTY. NORTON
AIR FORCE BASE WAS ONE OF THOSE
AND IT CLOSED AND JERRY EAVES
LED THE COALITION THE JPA TO
TAKE THAT THAT AIRPORT OVER AND
IT'S NOW IT'S CALLED THE SAMBAR
DINO INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT. THE
FOOTPRINT OF JERRY EAVES AND
WHAT HE BROUGHT TO SAN BENITO
COUNTY IS SOMETHING THAT WILL
NEVER BE FORGOTTEN I RISE TODAY
IN THE JOURNAL. MEMORY OF JERRY
EAVES. THANK YOU MISS ROSS
MISTER CALDERON. YOU ARE ALSO
RECOGNIZED ON THE STREET OR IN
MEMORY. MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ARRIVED TODAY TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF MY FRIEND OF OVER
THIRTY YEARS. JERRY WAS TOUGH
IS HE STILL HE MADE IS A STEEL
WORKER GET CHANNEL IS A TEDDY
BEAR WITH HIS GRANDCHILDREN AND
HIS WIFE GINA. THIS FRIEND FOR
MY POINTS WERE UNABLE TO HAVE A
FUNERAL TO KOBE SO I'M GLAD HER
REMEMBER HIM HERE IN THE HOUSE
HE LOVED SO MUCH. ONE OF MY
FIRST MEMORIES OF JERRY WITH
DURING A TOUGH REELECTION
CAMPAIGN. SEVERAL VOLUNTEERS.
FROM THROUGHOUT THE STATE HAD
DESCENDED UPON THE DISTRICT.
ALL THE LOCAL HOTELS WERE
BOOKED. FOR JERRY OPENED UP HIS
HOME. UNTIL EVERY SPARE BEDROOM
AND COUCH WITH FULL. NOT ONLY
DID HE OFFER VOLUNTEERS LODGING
BUT HE ALSO PROCEEDED TO COOK
FOR THEM BEFORE AND AFTER A
LONG DAY OF PRECINCT BLOCKY.
JERRY HAD A SENSE OF HUMOR AND
TO GIVE AS GOOD AS HE GOT. HE
WAS NOT ONE TO PARSE WORDS. HE
WAS A STRAIGHT SHOOTER. IF YOU
MADE A COMMITMENT YOU COULD
TAKE THAT TO THE BANK. HE WAS A
TRUE AND LOYAL FRIEND. I SAW
THIS UP CLOSE DURING THE GANG
OF FIVE DAYS. WHEN HE WAS ONE
OF FIVE DEMOCRATS WHO VOTED
TOGETHER WHERE THE SWING VOTE
ON THE FLOOR. I GOT INTO A
MINOR DISAGREEMENT WITH BEN
SPEAKER WILLIE BROWN. THE
SPEAKER CALL GERRY INTO HIS
OFFICE AND HE SAID JERRY.
WEARING AROUND THESE GUYS
YOU'RE TWENTY YEARS OLDER. YOU
HAVE NOTHING IN COMMON AND YOU
HAVE THE MOST TO LOSE AND JERRY
SAID BECAUSE THEY'RE MY FRIENDS.
MOST OF THE PROGRESSIVE IN THE
CARCASS LABEL JERRY A MODERATE.
HOWEVER NINE QUESTIONED HIS
COMMITMENT TO CIVIL RIGHTS.
JERRY WAS A STALWART ADVOCATE
FOR INDIVIDUAL FREEDOM. I WILL
MISS JERRY HIS SENSE OF HUMOR
HIS UNYIELDING FRIENDSHIP. AND
HIS HEART WITH ROOM ENOUGH FOR
ANYONE WHO NEEDED HIS HELP. HE
WILL BE REMEMBERED BY MANY FOR
THE GOOD SO HE WAS AND HIS
UNWAVERING DEDICATION TO PUBLIC
SERVICE. THANK YOU MISTER
CALDERON. MYSTERONS YOUR AGAIN
RECOGNIZE FOR INTERMENT IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY IN MEMORY
OF- RAYMOND ANTHONY IN A LOT
OF. I RISE TODAY TO REQUEST
THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
RAYMOND WHO ON PASSED AWAY ON
DECEMBER TENTH AT THE AGE OF
SIXTY FOUR. MR NAVARRO'S FAMILY
HAS RESIDED IN RIVERSIDE CASA
BLANKA SINCE NINETEEN TWENTIES
AND THEIR TIES TO THE COMMUNITY
ARE DEEP AND STRONG. ANTHONY
SERVED AS AN ALTAR BOY AT ST
ANTHONY'S CATHOLIC CHURCH ON
MADISON STREET. ALSO A PATROL
LEADER IN THE BOY SCOUT TROOP
NINETEEN. PLAYED IN THE COST OF
LIKE A LITTLE LEAGUE DELIVER
NEWSPAPERS AND SPENT TIME WITH
FRIENDS AT THE LATEST PART. RAY
WAS A GIVER. HE MANAGED THE
CASABLANCA LITERALLY
VOLUNTEERED AND WAS ACTIVE IN
ALL THE CORNERS COMMUNITY
SERVICES EVENTS SCHOLARSHIPS
AND FUNDRAISING ACTIVITIES.
ORGANIZE NONPARTISAN VOTER
REGISTRATION AND GET OUT THE
VOTE CAMPAIGNS IN LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. EVEN DURING HIS
UNIVERSITY DAYS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE WARY ORGANIZED EVENTS
SUCH AS THE CHICANO HIGH SCHOOL
VISITATION COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DAY AND THE OF AUDIO THAT UNITE
US KHAN CONFERENCE IT'S THERE.
I RISE TODAY TO ASK TO
ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY AND
THIS LEGISLATIVE FLOOR THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THANK YOU
MISS ROSS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I'M
SORRY. MISTER MEDINA IS ASKING
FOR RECOGNITION IN THE REAR OF
THE CHURCH. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I ALSO RISE
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF MY GOOD
FRIEND. RAY NEVADA. I FIRST MET
RAY WHEN HE WAS A FRESHMAN AT
UC RIVERSIDE. RATE WAS ONE OF
THE FIRST CHICANO STUDENTS FROM
RIVERSIDE THAT I MET AT UC
RIVERSIDE. THERE WERE STUDENTS
FROM ALL OVER THE AREA THE VERY
FEW STUDENTS SHE GOT A STUDENTS
FROM RIVERSIDE CASABLANCA. RAY
HAS BEEN A LIFELONG FRIEND. WE
PARTICIPATED TOGETHER IN MATCHA
WELL YOU SEE ARE. HE LIVED AS
MY COLLEAGUE MISTER RAMOS SAID
AND THE GUY SEES BANNEKER. IN
THE ANI DORMITORY HAVE YOU SEE
OUR- AFTER RAY GRADUATED HE
WENT ON TO WORK AT CSU. RATE
TOUCHED THE LIVES OF MANY YOUNG
PEOPLE IT WAS A VERY LOVING AND
KIND PERSON. HE WILL BE MISSED
BY ALL WHO KNEW HIM. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING IN THE MEMORY OF
RAIN ABOUT. THANK YOU MR MEDINA.
MISTER SMITH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
YES PHONE BILLS GO JOHN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I RISE
IN MEMORY OF WILLIAM BILL AUS.
PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY SIXTH.
AT THE AGE OF NINETY EIGHT
YEARS YOUNG. BILL WAS VERY
ACTIVE IN OUR COMMUNITY AND I
WAS HONORED TO SERVE WITH HIM
OF SEVERAL COMMUNITY BASED
NONPROFITS. AND BOARDS. WE WERE
VERY CLOSE FAMILY FRIENDS. BILL
WAS A WORLD WAR TWO VETERAN IN
THE US NAVY AND AN EDUCATOR IN
OUR COMMUNITY. BILL BEGAN HIS
CAREER IN REAL ESTATE IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN. AND MY
COMMUNITY. WARY SYSTEM
HOMEBUYERS OBTAINING THEIR
AMERICAN DREAM. EVENTUALLY
OPENING BILLS ALL STAR REALTY
HE WAS AN ALL STAR. BILL IS
ALSO IN THE COMMUNITY SERVING
IN ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THE
HONORARY MAYOR OF HYSTERIA
BEFORE THE CITY INCORPORATED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. HE WAS
ON HIS VERY A RECREATION AND
PARK DISTRICT BOARD. THE VICTOR
VALLEY COMMUNITY CONCERT SERIES.
PAST PRESIDENT OF THE QANTAS
CLUB IN A LONG TIME MEMBER OF
THE ELKS ORGANIZATION. HE IS
ALSO A GRADUATE OF USC. BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY HE WAS MARRIED
TO HIS WIFE EILEEN FOR SIXTY
ONE YEARS. THE FATHER OF. THREE
GRANDFATHER OF SIX. IN A GREAT
GRANDFATHER TO THREE OF HIS
GREAT GRAND CHILDREN. BILL WAS
A CLASS ACT IN A GENTLEMAN IN
OUR COMMUNITY HE WILL BE SORELY
MISSED. THANK YOU FOR HONORING
IN MEMORY OF BILL AUS. THANK
YOU MISTER SMITH. MR HOLDEN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER FOR YOUR
INTERMITTENTLY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I LIKE TO ADJOURN IN
THE MEMORY OF DR REVEREND DR
GEORGE F. REGUS GEORGE REGUS
WITH THE LEADER ONE OF THE MOST
ACTIVE AND INFLUENTIAL CHURCHES
AND MY DISTRICT ALL SAINTS
CHURCH. WHETHER ISSUE WAS
HUNGER EDUCATION WAR OR AIDS IN
HIS PARISHIONERS WERE VOCAL.
THE THIRTY KNOXVILLE TENNESSEE.
AND THOUGH HE WAS BAPTIZED IN
THE GREEK ORTHODOX CHURCH HE
ATTENDED THE LOCAL OF
HISTORICAL CHURCH TO FIND
CHRISTIAN COMMUNITY BECAUSE
THERE WAS NO ORTHODOX CHURCH.
HE LATER ATTENDED UNIVERSITY
TENNESSEE AND THEN MOVED TO
CAMBRIDGE MASSACHUSETTS. WHERE
HE COMPLETED THE ILLOGICAL
STUDIES BEFORE BECOMING
ORDAINED AS A DEACON IN
NINETEEN FIFTY SIX AND A PRIEST
IN NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN. HE
EARNED A DOCTORATE IN RELIGION
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO FROM
CLAREMONT COLLEGES. A SCHOOL OF
THEOLOGY AND THEN IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SEVEN HE WAS CALLED TO
ALL SAINTS CHURCH IN PASADENA
WHERE HE SERVED UNTIL NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE. WELL THERE HE
FOUGHT FOR WOMEN'S BOARD THAT
ORDINATION CIVIL RIGHTS
MARRIAGE EQUALITY AND REVERSING
THE ARMS RACE. HE WAS A POOR
MANAGER FOR THE COALITION THAT
ADVOCATED FOR WOMEN'S
ORDINATION WHEN THEY FINALLY
SUCCEEDED AT THE NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX GENERAL CONVENTION
OF THE EPISCOPAL CHURCH. HE
ALSO LED MANY EFFORTS TO
ADVOCATE FOR RIGHTEOUSNESS AND
RIGHTEOUS CAUSES WITH OTHER
RELIGIOUS LEADERS. LIKE
PARTNERING WITH DR MA HAIR HOW
TO OF ISLAMIC CENTER OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND RABBI
LEONARD BIERMAN. TO SPEAK
AGAINST THE GULF WAR AND WARS
FOLLOWING THE TWO THOUSAND ONE
TERRORIST ATTACKS. BERMAN
REVERT REGUS WAS A GOOD FRIEND
AND CONFIDANTE. HE PASSED AWAY
ON JANUARY THIRD AT NINETY
YEARS OF AGE. RITVIK REGUS WILL
BE SORELY MISSED HE WAS THE
ICON IN OUR COMMUNITY I THANK
YOU FOR JOINING AND IS A MEMBER.
THANK YOU MR HOLDEN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER YOU WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. FOR YOUR A GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I RISE TO JOIN IN
MEMORY OF FORMER SHERIFF SANDY
HUTCHINS IF YOU'RE IS LEADER.
LOVING WIFE. AND A GOOD FRIEND.
I CAN REMEMBER THE DAY WE VOTED
TO POINT HER TO BE THE NEXT
ORANGE COUNTY SHERIFF OVER TEN
YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS ON THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. SHE WAS AN
OUTSIDER SMART DEDICATED AND
PASSIONATE. TO PROTECT THE
RESIDENTS OF ORANGE COUNTY. SHE
WAS THE FIRST FEMALE SHERIFF IN
ORANGE COUNTY HISTORY. WE
FOUGHT SIDE BY SIDE TO MAKING
SURE ORANGE COUNTY STAY SAFE
AND TO PROTECT OUR NEIGHBORS.
AND FAMILIES IN OUR COMMUNITY.
FOLLOWING ENACT NATIONWIDE
SEARCH THAT PRODUCED OVER FORTY
EIGHT CANDIDATES. WE NEEDED
HELP ORANGE COUNTY NEEDED HELP.
SHARE PURCHASE WAS BORN IN
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE IN MONTEREY
PARK AND REYES IN LONG BEACH.
HUDGENS HAD A MIDDLE CLASS
SUBURBAN CHILDHOOD HER FATHER
WAS A CONSTRUCTION WORKER AND
HER MOTHER AN ASSEMBLY LINE
WORKER. THERE WERE SIGNS AT AN
EARLY AGE THAT SHE WAS A FEW
YEARS SHE WAS FIERCELY
INDEPENDENT. F. FIVE AND IN THE
FIRST CREATION SYSTEM MAKING.
THE TEN MINUTE WALK TO SCHOOL
BY HERSELF HER MOTHER SAID.
BACK IN THE BACK TO THE L. A.
TIMES IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
SHE GRADUATE FROM THE L. A.
COUNTY SHERIFF'S ACADEMY IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. WORKED
AS A DEPUTY AT THE END AT THE
WOMAN'S JAIL AND WAS
TRANSFERRED TO WORK PATROL. IN
LYNNWOOD ONE OF THE PARCHMENTS
BUSIEST AND MOST DANGEROUS
ASSIGNMENTS. SHE HELPED TO
REFORM A COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT ON MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS. WHY WOULD THE LOS
ANGELES SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT.
CHIEF HUDGENS ADDRESS DEPUTY
CORRUPTION IN THE CONDUCT
DIVISION. CROWDING IN THE
WOMAN'S JAIL THE MERGER THE
MARSHALLS DEPARTMENT TO THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. SHE'S
ALSO RESPONSE FOR THE CREATION
OF AND THAT THE L. A. COUNTY
OFFICE OF HOMELAND SECURITY.
SHE OVERSAW THE POLICE SERVICE
OF DOZENS OF CONTRACTS CITIES
IN LA. IN ORANGE COUNTY. SHE
SHE CAME ON BOARD. SHE HELPED
US MOVE AWAY. FROM OUR FOR HER
PRECEDENCE FROM- FORMER SHERIFF
MIKE CORONA WHO WAS INDICTED.
AND SHE REFORM AN ENTIRE
DEPARTMENT BUILDING TRUST BACK
INTO. THE DEPARTMENT AND FROM
THE PEOPLE. SHE'S A TRAILBLAZER
FOR WOMEN EMPLOYEES MANAGEMENT
AND A ROLE MODEL TO MANY.
THROUGH HER TENURE AS CHAIR.
ALTHOUGH WE DON'T ALWAYS AGREE
BUT I REMEMBER WHEN I SHARE MY
COME TOGETHER WE ARE FIERCE
FIGHTERS. AND WE CAN ALWAYS
DOES IT RESPECTFULLY. DISAGREE
WITH EACH OTHER. SANDY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK. YOUR
FRIENDSHIP. WE'RE GOING TO
COUNTY WILL MISS YOU. THANK YOU
FOR WHAT YOU'VE DONE. AND THANK
YOU FOR BEING SUCH A ROLE MODEL
TO ALL OF US. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO EVERYONE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOI. YOU ARE ALSO
RECOGNIZE INNOCENT GERMAN IN
MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ARE YOU TO STAND UP TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF A ONE AMAZING
WOMAN AND THE LEAD OR NOT
BECAUSE SO MANY ARE WAS
SADDENED TO LEARN OF THE
PASSING OF US TERRIBLE SANDRA
HUTCHENS SHARP HUTCHINS WELL
AND FAITHFULLY SERVED THE
RESIDENTS OF ORANGE COUNTY FOR
NEARLY A DECADE AS A SORROW.
SHE WAS ALL OUR FIRST A FEMALE
CHERYL FOR AN ORANGE COUNTY SHE
WAS ALWAYS A SMILING AS SHE
STEPPED IN IN A VERY TUMULTUOUS
TIME HOWEVER WITH- STRONG
LEADERSHIP. AND- SHE BOOSTED
THE- MORALE OF THE STAFF OF THE
DEPARTMENT AND DUSTERS SUCKS
THE SUCCESSFULLY LED THE
DEPARTMENT. I EXTEND MY DEEPEST
AND HEARTFELT. CONDOLENCES. TO
CHARLATANS FAMILY. SARPANCHES
WOULD BE MESSED UP BY SO MANY
AND WILL BE REMEMBERED FOR HER
STRENGTH. HER LEADERSHIP AND
THE WHOLE KOREJE. THANK YOU W.
CHOI. AND MISS DAVIS YOU ARE
ALSO RECOGNIZED THANK YOU. I
JUST BRIEFLY WANT TO TELL YOU A
COUPLE STORIES ABOUT SANDRA I
MET HER EIGHT YEARS AGO WHEN I
WAS ON CITY COUNCIL AND A
TALKING ABOUT BREAKING THE
GLASS CEILING THIS WASA WOMAN
THAT DID THIS I REMEMBER HER
TELLING US THAT. BACK THEN
WHICH WAS A DEPUTY SHE STILL
HAD TO WEAR SKIRTS AND PANTS
AND SHOULD REMEMBER AND LEARN
HOW TO RUN LIKE AND I'M SURE US
WOMEN HERE WE KNOW HOW
DIFFICULT THAT COULD BE. ALSO
SHE SAID THAT AT THAT TIME THEY
WEREN'T ALLOWED TO FEMALES TO
BE PARTNERS WELL THROUGH HER
HER SENSIBILITY AND PUSHING
THEY ALLOWED HER AND OTHER
WOMEN TO BECOME PARTNERS IN THE
CAR SO I MEAN SHE REALLY DID
PUSH THE ENVELOPE I'M SO PROUD
OF TO HAVE KNOWN HER SHE
SUPPORTED ME- THIS IS A WOMAN
WHO FOUGHT A VERY STRONG BATTLE
WITH CANCER. FOR MANY YEARS AND
I CAN TELL YOU SHE WAS A WOMAN
OF INTEGRITY STRENGTH AND
COURAGE AND I KNOW THAT I'M A
BETTER PERSON HAVING. BEEN
BLESSED TO HAVE HER IN MY LIFE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
DAVIS. THANK YOU MEMBERS. FOR
ME TO ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS
PLEASE NOTE THAT THE DEADLINE
TO SUBMIT LANGUAGE REQUEST TO
THE LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL. IS
THIS FRIDAY JANUARY TWENTY
SECOND THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS
AS FOLLOWS. WEDNESDAY JANUARY
TWENTIETH NO FLOOR SESSION NO
CHECK IN SESSION. THURSDAY
JANUARY TWENTY FIRST FLOOR
SESSION AND NINE AM ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
TO RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SINGER IN A FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN IS REYES
MOVES SECONDED BY MISS WALDRON
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
JANUARY TWENTY FIRST. AT NINE
AM IN THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.